and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 2 oh yeah this is a
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
doo doo doo doo doo dis boy is here's
his boy named Harry Potter and everybody
agrees that he's the world's most
special little boy and that everybody
who knows him dies seriously
don't get close to this kid you will
perish luckily I might add and he's
accompanied by his two friends
hermaphrodite in row weasel
or as I like to call them cat tease and
wimp and they had to make it back to the
school of hogwash because they're afraid
that's gonna be under attack by this man
with no no is insert Michael Jensen Jo
can't wait for left but enter the hog
what is taken over by the British a ho
will always place a British a ho and
he's like everyone who knows where Harry
Potter is stand forward and father is
like when I'm here we powdered a second
yes I suppose along but then the nun
from Sister Act comes in and with their
wizards ask goons out for her but then
the British 8th hole goes in tells the
man with no nose and a man with no nose
it's like making me Harry Potter when do
you want any budget because someone has
to know how to hold me still but enough
resistor exits out a punch a knight's
armor to fight them metric oh no I'm all
quite easy I mean oh wee oh wee oh
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
another this big action scene that just
like Return of the King actually I'm
tired of people saying this is ripping
off a whole bunch of other fantasies
just because there's a great big action
scene in this castle to keep place with
giant rolls and even some giant spiders
there's an afterlife scene with a wizard
with a long beard in white robe and had
to destroy an object in order to destroy
the main villain I totally forget where
I was going with this so as all the
wizards are fighting we all the bad guys
know knows goes to that British a-hole
okay yeah yo I need your Wang Oh take
you Harry Potter so and I need to kill
you Wow are you happy to hear that
no it's magic no I'm better this diary
batteries like you really we're pretty
Genie holy no it's not true I just tried
to sleep with your mother Oh
your enemy Malfoy by killing Dumbledore
right I am an a-hole but Harry Potter
takes his tears important metric toilet
of history any season why is the British
a whole just not that big of a British a
whole I was a British a whole once my
father Simon Cowell please daddy started
teaching my messages to take me back to
Harry Potter finally says if I'm going
to - you know knows you have to tell me
okay
Oh Harry ends up in this really white
train station must be Arkansas and a
person in a long white beard and white
clothes stands before him God get off
the white Richard Harris clothes that
guy's on clean slate you saw that hey
Harry Potter is like am i dead no Harry
because he killed you a little bit of
him died but a little bit of you didn't
die just or went to this weird place I
don't know why a little bit of you
didn't die but I guess there's a lot of
you to go around its a popular franchise
that makes no freakin sense so Harry and
Ono start shooting their beans at each
other and one lets out a red beam and
the other lets out of green beam just
like that internet movie that came out
recently suburban kites I think it was
called but then suddenly no no's gets
really weak Oh somebody injured my
little snake I'm dead now so we then cut
to 19 years later we're now Harry Potter
has become Baldy patter and it turns out
she's singing his little one - ha glutes
- are you not this is our school in the
world like what's a fatality rate up to
where are they even funding from the men
in black if I thought back to the most
traumatic experience where all my
friends died I wouldn't be like yeah I
want my kid to go through that this is a
horrible school they'd be shut down in a
wig but the movie was all sort of
awesome and everything magic spiders
important no nose people on their
benches it was awesome Mac so I hate to
admit I'm really gonna miss the fifth I
have no more Harry Potter movies to look
forward to but it's okay there's
something just as equally good coming
out this summer everyone in the Morpher
Twilight this is jittery bum singh
change you can change i come on every
guy yeah can I change
come on a home make another Harry Potter
movie Harry Potter and the curse of the
Sabre keep is